all right I see a couple people in the
audience who've already seen a good
number of these slides and in fact one
in the audience who I stole a number of
these slides from so yeah in the
meantime if you've seen these slides or
in there and I know a little bit later
they're gonna get a little dry in places
I suggest you go to the Microsoft blog
on Monday we recently put out a a note
on some work that we've been doing
recently with Case Western Reserve
University on quantum inspired
algorithms in particular using quantum
inspired algorithms to improve magnetic
residents fingerprinting okay and so we
can produce MRI scans with higher
resolution and a fraction of the time
that they now run now obviously this is
research and so by the time it gets to
market maybe some years to come but this
really has the up an opportunity to
change the way we do healthcare
diagnosis in the future okay also on the
blog you'll find from a couple weeks ago
a collaboration with willows Towers
Watson a major insurance firm also using
quantum inspired algorithms to improve
the speed and efficiency of risk
modeling which of course is with one of
the major components and insurance and
so quantum inspired algorithms mother
real and they're here today and so my
name is Brad Lackey I'm a principal
researcher I will be your substitute
lecturer for this talk matthias Troyer
was really hoping to give this himself
but unfortunately is out of the country
today so I'll be covering this I'm gonna
talk about chemistry but on a day to day
basis I work in quantum inspired
optimization okay so I think a little
since questions came up I'll take a
little bit of time at the beginning to
talk about this rather than at the end
there are multiple modal modes of
quantum computing or million bottles of
quantum computing is amour traditional
way of saying it what I'm going to talk
about here is really these chemistry
applications are based on the gate model
approach which is really the focus of
this entire workshop but there are other
models so for instance if you study
cryptography some popular cryptographic
protocols such as multi
computation or blind computation there
are quantum versions of that but they're
not built on the gate model like we're
gonna see today but they're built on
another model of computation called
measurement based quantum computation
okay in that setting you don't have a
circuit like we're going to see a lot
you have what's called a cluster state
or just a large entangled state and you
make small measurements on pieces of it
and adaptively tune those to push the
computation in the direction you want to
go and so it looks very different
another model is adiabatic quantum
computing which is really what I
specialize in also a universal model
this is based on old ideas from physics
the adiabatic theorem which came around
in the 1920s so it's been around for a
hundred years in this case you prepare a
system which you sort of understand
everything about so it's easy to
construct and then slowly transform that
system into one whose lowest energy
configuration solves the problem of
interest and the adiabatic theorem says
as long as this transformation moves
slowly enough the system will stay in
that lowest energy configuration and so
at the end you've solved the problem
okay and in many ways adiabatic quantum
computing isn't as popular today because
it's been around for a hundred years and
so there's a huge amount of machinery to
simulate this type of physics okay and
so we have very very good classical
algorithms we can run on computers today
that will simulate adiabatic evolution
ok so if I can take an adiabatic quantum
algorithm and these are optimization
algorithms are really easy to cast in
the adiabatic model then we can simulate
these on computers we have today and so
we're actually are running quantum
algorithms but we're running simulations
of what would happen sometimes they're
not perfect simulations they're
analogous simulations of what would
happen and solving problems using these
algorithms and so that often goes to the
name of quantum inspired optimization ok
and so that's if you read through our
blog post you'll see we have a lot of
partnerships almost all of our corporate
partnerships are based on that
optimization is a big deal in industry
huge deal in industry ok and so any type
of speedups solving highly non convex
large optimization problems are gonna
have real applications okay but that's
that's something completely different
because adiabatic adiabatic optimization
adiabatic quantum computing is is a hard
way to think about computing we've sort
of grown up with computers uh in sort of
von Neumann architecture 'z that we're
familiar with today where you have a
register and you apply some gates to a
register and that makes sense to us
intuitively and so to develop algorithms
is much easier since we have that
intuition to do it even though
developing quantum algorithms itself is
a very very hard task developing a model
that's completely alien to us is even
harder ok so there's really not a lot of
adiabatic quantum algorithms out there
because they're very very challenging to
come up with okay so so instead we're
going to focus on some gate model stuff
and in particular I'm going to talk
about a collaboration that we had with
Pacific Northwest National Labs and
integrating their quantum chemistry
package in W chem into using the Q take
what a development kit the qdk and a non
Calmes little big it going so so quantum
programming well that's what it's all
about as far as I'm concerned alright so
we want to develop algorithms but we
want to run those algorithms and so to
run these algorithms we need a
programming language to work with and
here I'm going to talk about Q sharp
that being the the the topic of the day
and so really what I'll focus on today
is using a implementation of an
algorithm and Q sharp to count the
number of gates and qubits that are
necessary to run the algorithm to get an
understanding of when quantum computers
come around how long is this really
going to take ok so initial estimates of
of a classical algorithm just make it
completely intractable but if you take
the naive quantum algorithm just write
it out and start counting the number of
gates those are huge numbers they would
just make it totally impossible even for
quantum computers but as we refactor
these algorithms we find better ways of
implementing them we find better tricks
for computing pieces of them we reduce
the the resource costs we could
eventually get these much more efficient
implementations which make these things
tractable when sufficiently large
quantum computers come around
okay so resource estimation is a good
way of looking forward even though we're
not necessarily going to run these on
quantum computers a day to estimate what
the impact of these algorithms will be
on industrial workflows in ten years or
fifteen years or whatever timeframe were
really talking about okay so the the
problem that keeps me awake at night is
this one
I've been debugging quantum algorithms I
have enough time debugging classical
algorithms so so yeah I mean I Christmas
chuckling because this is his slide and
so he printed off this this output but
this is exactly what I see whenever I
write code and run it is is just this
complete mess
and so quantum algorithms this is a real
challenge debuggers as we understand
them today use sort of the same basic
tools right you set a breakpoint you
look in there you see what state is and
is that what you expected well in
quantum algorithms you can't do that if
you examine the state you've destroyed
the coherence the entanglement all of
the nice quantum properties of that
state that you want to actually complete
the algorithm so you may see some
statistics at this point but that might
not give you a clue about where this
where the where the state is moving to
right so the concept of using
breakpoints and debugging in that
fashion just isn't going to work right
well what else is there
yeah all right so so I lose a little bit
I'll just a lot of sleep over that but
what I'm going to talk about today is is
actually bringing applications today
using using quantum algorithms ok so so
this is really what I do on a day to day
basis because well debugging stuff is
too hard all right so so we've already
seen the notion of a stack indeed we're
really today we're going to talk about I
guess what's most
sort of hovering at the top of that top
squiggly arrow there okay I'm going to
talk about chemistry but we're gonna
have a lot of other algorithms that we
talked about this afternoon and really
we're talking how do we implement them
how do we create a code that would push
them down into the control software and
I guess below that we're really not
going to discuss that too much that's
some complicated engineering and and
that's that's really far away from from
what I do and so I'm afraid I can't
really comment on that but what sort of
applications can we see for for for
quantum algorithms so quantum chemistry
looks particularly attractive because of
these numbers along the bottom when we
run these resource counts we think that
yes we can get real payoff in the
hundreds of 200 qubit range okay so so
putting some numbers forward the we
mention of the IBM Q which is there the
quantum machine that they have in New
York the original one that was on the
web had five cubits the new one has 49
in a kind of interesting topology I
don't know exactly what the how big the
next generation is going to be but we're
already starting to see this this become
realistic a couple years ago Google
promised the Bristlecone ship which was
to have 72 qubits in a sort of grid like
topology but we haven't seen that appear
yet ion Q over in Maryland is promising
128 qubits those are ions I don't know
how they're gonna fit that into a linear
trap but you know Kris Munroe is a smart
guy so these numbers don't look so
outrageous now of course those are going
to be very very noisy computers okay and
so so even though the sizes of them were
in the ranges we're talking about the
length of the program you can run is
going to be very very short before the
noise and decoherence overruns it okay
and so so yes these numbers say all
right yes we could talk about small
quantum computers we can think about
these but we also have to have long run
times and that's where we have to worry
now do we use this error correction on
these noisy things or do
attempt to build a topological quantum
computer say when the noise is small
enough that we might be able to run
these without the need for additional
error correction ok on the other hand
things like Shor's algorithm are in the
thousands of qubits and so that sort of
out of range material sciences also
grows pretty big machine learning of
course is a huge promise but there's a
lot of uncertainties in the applications
to machine learning there's a little bit
of a war going on there every time we
get a new quantum algorithm that
improves machine learning somebody comes
and D quantizes it and says well here's
the classical algorithm that will do
just as good all right so there's been a
lot of back and forth on that for the
past few years and so I'm not sure where
that's gonna finally end up all right so
let me let me just recapture what I said
there in the near term we have these
these machines that are coming out now
most of them are based on
superconducting qubits the the one
exception the one at ion cubing ion trap
topological things are still I mean I
don't know because I don't work the
hardware but there's they're not here
yet the length of the program because
probably talking about you know a
thousand one thousand what well let's
say it may be a thousand cycles or the
analog of what a cycle would be the
computer so a thousand time steps to get
your algorithm done and that's not
nearly enough to do any significant size
size algorithm on the other hand if we
want over here we want to have these
really long term programs and we can run
millions and or even billions of cycles
which are going to be necessary then
we're going to need to do something to
control the air hey either get the air
correction
directly in the the physical qubit
itself or build air correction on top of
it okay so so what I'm going to talk
about really is quantum phase estimation
that's the underlying algorithm that's
really driving a lot of these these
chemistry applications and it belongs to
this category over here it's
unfortunately a relative relatively deep
algorithm it takes a long time to run
even though we might not require as many
qubits
okay so so the other words we're not
there yet okay but you know five to five
years ten years we might be running up
against the boundaries of what we can
actually do and of course at that point
then we want to use it all right so so
here's an example of something that you
might actually want to see come out of
one of these simulations theory has a
predicted curve which relates the bond
length and in a water sorry a hydrogen
molecule here with the associated energy
and we'd like to simulate around this
low point because that's going to be
where we find the the system at
equilibrium okay so the methodology for
this uses the same methodology we've
used for these sort of things for well I
mean forever you somehow get the theory
out of some research paper you know you
go up to the whiteboard and you work out
what it is in terms of the simulation
that you can do and then you cut and
paste it into your simulator you know
being in MATLAB or now in NQ sharp and
an outcome some plots which hopefully
match pretty well with the theory that's
been developed over the years okay so so
very very intensive and not scalable to
to large things okay so so what we did
is team up with Pacific Northwest
National Labs which have the product NW
chem which is a high power quantum
chemistry tool this is really what the
what they work with that's this is their
specialty and integrate all of the
wonderful modeling that they have going
on in that tool and bring it into the
qkd so that we can simulate it directly
and not have to go through the human
intensive step of converting all of the
various pieces to the right form that we
can then put into simulators okay and so
so here it's basically a four step
process I'll go through a little bit of
these broome bridge is the name of the
protocol this doesn't really have
anything to do with what I'm talking
about today but it's such a nice picture
that I just had to include
this is the the the this is broom bridge
I guess is what it is it's over the the
river over a river in Dublin and the
link if you will
you'd have to probably look a little bit
for this is that this is the bridge
where Sir Rowan Hamilton
famously invented the rules for the
Kearney uns okay and so what does that
have to do with quantum chemistry well
you know we use Hamiltonians and the
names Hamilton so maybe a little bit
tenuous there but but it's a great
picture so so I laughs a great story but
that gives us a format for linking sort
of gluing these two pieces of
sophisticated software together we can
get all of the appropriate chemical
information that we'd like using the
modelling tools and in W cam and here we
see examples of this and then this can
be brought directly into appropriate
tools to transform it into a cue sharp
simulator for the phase estimation or
and and other other type algorithms for
estimating energy levels both ground
state and excited state energies okay so
so this is a little bit you know
flashing code up there's no fun
unfortunately I'm going to get a little
bit more of that but we're gonna see a
lot more of it as the day goes on
here's really what's what's at stage the
workflow here is about four steps and
this is characteristic of just about any
real-world application you can imagine
okay you have some method of taking
something of interest and then mapping
it into a simple algorithm that you can
run on a computer right now every stage
of that mapping typically has dozens of
options you can choose from
and so finding a method which will
actually get your result requires sort
of searching over all of these things
okay and and of course you know that's
that's really where we're in computer
ages really brought us forward and in
technologies because we could
automatically do those things you know
if I wanted to find a fast algorithm
for computing you know something in the
in the 19th century I was you know
digging through long tables and stuff
like that and that was just no fun okay
but now we can go through all kinds of
different options test them all out and
and and just find what's the best and
that is the method for going from this
3,000 year estimate to run this quantum
algorithm down to this one day estimate
during this quantum algorithm it's how
do we choose the best of these to make
an efficient implementation okay so I'm
gonna briefly run through these just you
know if you're interested in in quantum
chemistry and simulation of these things
all this this work that we've done on
the the chemistry library within the qdk
has all of these little steps well maybe
I shouldn't say all these little steps
it has at least one of the major choices
for each of the steps in the reduction
okay so and and I'm gonna flash up this
pretty quickly because I want to get to
the get to the point but the the docs
actually explain everything that's going
on and there's sample code available and
so if you want to construct the
Hamiltonian or and then use like Jordan
or video representation to convert it
into some qubits then the explanation of
all that is there and then the the
utilities for doing this has already
been prepared deriving a qubit
Hamiltonian again everything's in there
if you go on to the docs you can read
about this it's very interesting what
I'd like to spend time on here is
discussing the simulation algorithms
because there's a lot of choices that
can happen we'd like to implement
Hamiltonian dynamics which we can see in
this slide going on right here
maybe the font is not an ideal choice
but so we'd like to implement unitary
dynamics given by a Hamiltonian and the
Hamiltonian is given by the sum of
sparse Hamiltonians are simple to apply
hamiltonians and so there's a mechanism
for doing that and here we're
illustrating trotter Suzuki but there
are many many more qubit ization is
another one Taylor series is a third and
so at each of those have numerous
parameters and so that how do we how do
we find the right thing to do
and and run these okay before I talk
more about that let me just illustrate
what the output looks like okay so
here's the actual workflow what we start
with is our R in W CEM box as far as I'm
concerned which has all of the quantum
chemistry built into it that people can
utilize I'm not a quantum chemist myself
and so that really is a black box for me
somebody says we're really interested in
say nitrogen aise which is the enzyme
that has the fomo co molecule inside of
it and so that might be modeled up here
under this bio models biomolecules data
that sends in an appropriate database
and that can be manipulated and and then
exported in this brew bridge file which
then can go through the cue sharp
simulator we go through a variety of
choices on how we select our options and
then target in this case a resource
estimator to say is that option really a
good one for simulating this complex
molecule and so how long would that take
and and then go back and forth so what
we'd like to see is something that looks
like this so here lithium hydride
simulation we like to understand these
the ground state and and excited state
curves of how they of their bond length
because at the lowest one that's going
to be where we have our are stable or
stable States okay and so and so here
we're just seeing some outputs of some
simulators you have the ground state we
simulate the first excited state there's
some outliers as well as one would
expect but one can then put all this
together and get a good estimates get
good empirical plots of the spectrum of
this molecule using these tools this is
a very small one and so the the theory
plots can be constructed directly and so
it's a nice a nice example home-ice
chemistry experiment here
it's it's what so much the ones we're
looking at here so for instance this is
just simulating the ground state and a
couple of things didn't quite come out
right here where let me let me go up and
erase the the front one here and here
we're simulating the first excited state
and so you can see the outputs of the
simulator tracking the energy levels for
the first excited state so we built that
in I don't understand why it why it's
producing things way up in the in the in
nowhere land that's kind of curious yeah
you got those yep it'll wrap around okay
yep and then pop it way up there yep
great thanks okay so yeah so ultimately
what we're looking for is a plot like
this where we can see all of the
spectral lines of the molecule alright
so let's look a little bit of this
resource estimation there's a variety of
options we have for hamiltonian
simulation and each of them have
different requirements in terms of the
number of qubits that are required now
as we expect we're gonna have limited
number of qubits so that's a major
concern by the training off that we also
have the number of gates that are
required which is the length of the
program that's going to run and so we'd
like that to be short as well well as
expected those are fighting against each
other and so there's a variety of
choices we might want to make but in
terms of actually doing it all of this
is already built into the qdk and so
it's relatively straightforward we're
seeing well pretty much all of the code
right here now
you know here we have this thing called
Trotter step Oracle which of course
requires a great deal of work to build
and go on how I imagine has done a great
deal of work in making this making this
practical but but really once it's built
into the the Oracle once it's built into
the qtk itself it's relatively
straightforward to use okay and so and
here we can just estimate now the cost
of Trotter step Oracle's based on some
ideas you know what do we think would be
good how many what order do we want do
we want to do a first-order
approximation like linear approximation
we wanted quadratic approximations etc
and what's the size of the steps we'd
like to make and
we can tune those to see what see what
comes out of it okay so I guess this
this slide is a little bit older than I
was expecting although I hope it's still
up to date I in fact want to get the
Python one in here but I didn't so this
is the the c-sharp wrapper that goes
around that that Q sharp piece of code
you'll probably see a lot more of this
this afternoon and really this little
four four line statement right there is
the in some sense the driver which is
running the quantum computer if you will
now here we're just doing a gate count
simulator but but this is telling us to
run this Trotter step algorithm to
simulate a Hamiltonian and three of the
four lines are about getting timings
okay and then the bottom areas here this
is just getting statistics that we can
then print off to the screen and I'll
show the picture of that in a moment
or at least a graphic that comes out of
this but really there's not a lot to
running the code itself takes a little
bit of getting used to but then you can
create very very efficient code bases
that automates this task really really
well all right so this is just the the
Trotter case and so here is the output
that comes out of that there's a variety
of choices we talked about the the
Trotter one here cubed ization is
another one then there's an optimized
qubit ization which attempts to reduce I
believe in this case it's reducing the
the number of rotations I believe it is
okay well be that as it may you get
these outputs from the simulator for all
kinds of different molecules it's a
little bit time-consuming to do it but
we actually can count the number of
gates that are required to do each of
these okay so for instance on this
ferric sulfide I'm not sure where it is
in the table here does not appear to be
there but it's on the chart that's
will appear later there's a variety of
choices we can take the Trotter
for instance gives us a certain number
of rotations and a certain number of see
not gates in some sense that's relevant
to the to the depth of the circuit
there's a more computation that has to
be done to get that if we want to do
error corrected things which would be
appropriate for the modern modern
superconducting based computers the T
count
t gates are the stumbling block and so
we'd want to count those and the
optimized one it's reduced the number of
non T rotations to something that's
manageable like 18 but still we have
what 69 million T gates which tells us I
mean that's really gonna be the
quantifier of how hard is this gonna be
to run okay and then with some
assumptions this sort of guides the
statement that oh we can do this in a
day with an appropriate T state
factories that have been lined up in the
right way and that's complex but but
really all I want to want to do here is
say that we have all these different
options that can be automated and then
we can find efficient implementations by
searching through these hyper parameters
and selecting the best okay so just a
quick overview of what all of these do
minimizes T count that's the optimized
one over there and so you know we can
choose which are the best possible and
the the answer is well of course it's
going to vary on what you actually want
to do and so the choice for a small
molecule might not be the same as the
choice for a larger molecule it'll vary
from one to the other and so one has
this now workflow that's been designed
that can optimize this for all of the
possible choices that you might be
interested in okay so let me let me call
up a quick picture here okay so here is
the lamoco molecule here as part of the
nitrogen a is enzyme okay it's actually
living living out here so so what we see
is a along the top of these charts these
these top lines are these are white
board results right we get up on the
white board we say all right well here's
how the algorithm work
let me think about how I would want to
implement it and prove some upper bounds
on its runtime okay because I can get an
implementation that I that takes only
this long according to these asymptotics
and heuristics and one might use these
get better and better as time goes on
but then we can then we can run these
counts and the simulators at least up to
the size that our simulators will run on
to to validate where the real runtimes
are for these types of molecules all
right so getting to the end here
I stole a slide from our marketing group
because it has sort of nice pictures on
it and hopefully this is very
motivational so so our goal again is to
to be over here where we can model these
large molecules with a large number of
atoms classical computing is just not
going to be tractable now you cannot see
that curve on there at all
okay there is a very dark grey curve
running up here indeed these are all
exponential algorithms and so they very
very quickly become in computing with
classical methods yeah yeah it really it
really is there but I can see I'm
standing like right right up against the
screen here but but quantum computers
while they are physical devices and so
it's not surprising in some sense that
they're very good simulating physical
devices and so we can think of the
quantum computer itself as a
programmable physics lab okay it's
actually estimating what's going on in a
computation by doing the underlying
physics that the computation is is
modeling all right so so let me finish
with this is well so the same slide so
this is a outlook of what we're gonna do
a little bit later this afternoon and
and some links if you want to look up
look up all of these and even get
started early and I'm happy to take
questions I'll reserve a little bit of
extra time because you know I hear we
have result you know people want to hear
about the quantum inspired stuff as well
and so I'm happy to talk
about that in in more detail or anything
else
I mean floors yours thank you
No yeah what a clarifying question up
what is the so you explained a lot about
the process that goes into developing
these things yes what is the process of
finding fields where a quantum quantum
computer can be useful in some sense
right okay so so yeah in other words how
do you develop new quantum algorithms
right that's that's a very very
challenging challenging process and I
guess it depends on on if you're
interested more in combinatorial things
and and robins sitting here in the front
row so I might have tap him to answer
some of this if you're looking for for
those then there's sort of one approach
that that that you can probe more
computer science types approaches if you
want to look at like real world
applications those often don't fall into
these more combinatorial things they're
more continuous valued and such and it's
and you know it's like developing any
algorithm it's a it's a one-off you gain
inspiration about the algorithm itself
about the problem itself and then find
new ways of examining it okay so there
are some very very broad categories that
work and I've mentioned it's already a
quantum inspired optimization so
adiabatic so at a very general level
adiabatic quantum computing is well
tuned to optimization because what it's
doing is finding the lowest energy
configuration of a Hamiltonian and so if
I want an optimization solve an
optimization problem I just cast that
optimization that objective function as
the Hamiltonian and then the adiabatic
process itself will will find that now
the hard part isn't actually just
writing down the algorithm that's the
that's in some sense the easy part the
hard part is analyzing how long is it
going to take to resolve this how long
is it going to run okay and what's the
likelihood that it's actually going to
find the solution that we want to find I
mean all of this is randomized these are
all randomized algorithms okay but but
yeah I don't think there's any easy
answer I like you know I wanted to find
a new quantum algorithm today what do I
have to do well no no easy response
there yep
yep a couple of sighs there is a it's a
bunch of grafts next one yeah okay oh
yeah so you want this this one or this
one huh next okay this one here next one
yep that one okay right so what I didn't
understand in this graph these are all
very interesting but at the lower left
you've got the Microsoft simulations
that's right so so this is once we get
the the Q sharp program written out this
of the quantum algorithm written out in
terms of the code we can just simulate
what's going on okay so if I have say 20
cubits well 20 spin orbitals which then
get converted into roughly 20 cubits 20
plus o of 1 I think it's a statement
then I can just write that as a vector
of those amplitudes
ok so let's pretend it was 20 for the
moment and so I'd have 2 to the 20
complex amplitudes so a million complex
amplitudes I store in memory and then
every time I apply a gate I just adjust
those amplitudes according to the action
of the gate all right so at the end of
the program I have the all these
amplitudes I just sample it ok and so
those those plots were all those red red
dots appeared that was what was coming
out of these sampler you sample it you
get it you actually get the there was
the result of the of the simulation ok
but if you start scaling this up and so
you know up here I don't know what
number that is say 24 25 you know the
this is becoming very memory intensive
okay so we're already talking to the
megabytes these are complex numbers of
memory available obviously we get to
gigabytes now without too much
difficulty if we move this up on to the
cloud using Azure that we can get this
up to 30 maybe 35 cubits just because
that's it takes a huge amount of memory
to store all the amplitudes for that
quantum state yeah these are all theory
lines here this is the resource counter
right so the resource counter doesn't
actually simulate it just says well how
long is this going to take based on all
of these gates that I've counted and the
number of time steps that I predict it's
gonna it's going to run there's a
current Q sharp suffered toolkit that
it's contained
simulator but also there's County yeah
contains simulator and the resource
counter both and there and it's just a
one line switch to go between the two do
you instantiate the simulator and then
it runs the simulation or do you
instantiate the resource counter and
more or less the except for some trace
commands you know the QR codes the same
run the simulator on a t-cubed no
probably not on 80 cubits out that would
not be great although 70 might be in
range for certain things okay so so
going back to these quantum inspired
algorithms the the Bristlecone when
google put that at announce that a
couple years ago and they said they
wanted to run what's called low depth
circuits which is a technical name as
well this was going to be for their
supremacy experiment they were going to
say that well with these low def
circuits now we can sample from
distributions you cannot sample from
classically right and to say not sample
from classically means of course not
sample from classically in any
reasonable amount of time okay so a few
friends of mine down at NASA Ames well
they have a great big huge supercomputer
they're called Pleiades and they were
able to take this low depth quantum
circuit problem and recast it as tracing
a tensor network okay so this is really
long exact same lines of these quantum
inspired things we know we have a
quantum algorithm it's gonna be hard to
simulate that but we can estimate that
using a slightly different means in this
case tensing at tracing a tensor network
and then we're able to do that up into
the 50 qubit range and they predicted
that you know with about a day's runtime
on the pleiades supercomputer they could
do 72 qubits all right so so 72 qubits
are is then now that's in the is that Li
quantum inspired range now well at least
for maybe low depth circuits it is for
these really long circuits this this
techniques not going to work so the
boundary between what's quantum and
what's quantum inspired is always moving
yep yeah yeah it's a quantum annealer
and so so quantum annealing is sort of
the the community name for adiabatic
quantum computing at nonzero temperature
okay so temperature thermal fluctuations
having a real effect in that machine we
can't you know zero temperature doesn't
exist in reality we're always going to
be in a non zero temperature and so they
run it a handful of millikelvin but
thermal effects actually do have a
non-trivial effect on the dynamics of
that machine but what is what it's meant
to do is simulate adiabatic quantum
computing using a quantum device now
it's very incoherent but but it's
actually a pretty amazing pretty amazing
piece of machinery again really easy to
simulate using other methods like
quantum Monte Carlo or diffusion Monte
Carlo because we have the knowledge of
simulating these using different types
of algorithms okay Thank You Brad thank
you